long symposium on the vietnam war hosted
by the national archives in
collaboration with the assembly for
democracy in vietnam
so the session the second session of the
symposium deals with the aftermath of
the war
it falls in the aftermath
of lunch so please be alert
and pay attention to our four speakers
five speakers here
now they will tell us why
south vietnam lost the war
how vietnamese refugees were settled in
the u.s
and what lessons we can learn from the
vietnam war
so
let me introduce our first speaker
first speaker is dr robert turner whose
topic is the neglected political
struggle
why vietnam and his allies lost the war
dr turner is a distinguished fellow at
the center for national security law at
the university of virginia law
so please give a round of applause for
dr turner thank you
it is a great pleasure to be here and i
have a problem i have probably 45
minutes worth of material to cover in 15
minutes and if you will give me a
three-minute warning and a one-minute
warning i will try very hard to stop
after 15 minutes i want to thank our
sponsors to begin with
it is often said that america was
winning the war but after we left the
south vietnamese lost it
i don't agree with that
i think america lost the war i think
specifically the american congress lost
the war and i'll explain why i think
that in reality i think the south
vietnamese soldiers fought bravely
heroically in many cases
but they did not stand a prayer so long
as north vietnam had so much equipment
from china and the soviet union it was
just no way they could survive without
the aid we had promised them for many
many years
in vietnam we often talked about the
importance of winning the hearts and
minds of the vietnamese people
what we didn't talk about
and didn't pay attention to was
maintaining the hearts and minds of the
american people
and i used the word maintaining
intentional rather than winning because
we went to war with the overwhelming
support of the american people
lbj's approval rating and the gallup
poll which has been going on since the
1940s you approve of disapprove of the
way the president's doing his job shot
up 30 points in the months surrounding
his first attacks against north vietnam
in august of 1964. that was a 58
increase
unmatched in history until i believe the
nine with the week after 9-1-1 for
george w bush also had a spike and i
don't know whether it was that big or
not
congress almost immediately authorized
an aumf an authorization for the use of
military force a joint resolution a
statute the same type of statute
congress uses to declare war
by a
504-2 margin a
99.6
vote percent vote you can round it up if
you want to
the two dissenters the two senators who
voted against it lost their next
re-election bids
and both congress and the public
strongly supported the war
overwhelmingly until about the time of
the tet offensive
several factors undercut our support
including public frustration over a
no-win war policy which did horrible
damage to us
ignoring the advice of military leaders
is
ignoring the intelligence community
uh politicians who knew nothing about
the military uh said oh these are just a
bunch of they're not even very tall none
of very few of them speak english you
know how serious can they be as an
opponent our opponents were very
good they were smart they were clever
they were brave
uh they committed all kinds of war
crimes we'd talk about that later but
including the crime of aggressive war
but
we underestimated them horribly and paid
a tremendous price for it hanoi and its
friends ran a brilliant political war
campaign
to turn the american people against the
war
and it worked very well they relied
heavily on the so-called peace movement
i say so-called because everyone favors
peace
uh some of these people no doubt were
sincere but some of them also had
ideological reasons to support the
communists and some of them after
hearing that we had blocked free
elections and were promoting a dictator
who
routinely brutalized his people and ho
chi minh was vietnam's george washington
and the rightful leader of the country
they didn't want their country
supporting dictators or blocking free
elections
now i have a 10 000 word conference
paper that i gather is being made
available it will include the footnotes
i've written about this at some length
in 1972 i did a
they used the whole issue of southeast
asian perspective for a monograph i used
the pentagon papers to shoot down the
major myths being promulgated by the
anti-war movement and it shot down
virtually all of them
i then did a 500 plus page it was the
first english history of vietnamese
communism when i was a fellow at
stanford hoover institution
and more recently i co-edited a uh a
volume on the real lessons of the war
that was based upon a conference we held
down at uva on the 25th anniversary of
the fall of saigon
it was clear to me at the time
and if you shared by doug pike bill
colby
bob sorley harry summers and many others
that south vietnam and u.s forces were
winning the war by the early 1970s and
indeed several former north vietnamese
and vietcong officials have acknowledged
the same point in the mid 1990s colonel
bowie 10 told my friend steve young
whose father was mentioned earlier today
he was our ambassador to thailand
from 1965 the politburo knew they could
never defeat your forces their only hope
was success by the anti-war movement in
the united states
he said of the ted offensive our losses
during tet were staggering and a
complete surprise bowen [ __ ] later told
me ted had been in military defeat
uh trung du chang the minister of
justice of the vietcong's provisional
revolutionary government the truth is
tech cost us half of our forces our
losses were so immense we were simply
unable to replace them with new recruits
after tet and the may offensive
virtually all the fighting on the
communist side in south vietnam was by
nva regulars
uh i'm going to skip over that what went
wrong
well under pressure from anti-war peace
activists
in may of 1973 congress by statute
snatched defeat from the jaws of victory
congress virtually threw in the tower
they passed a statute that said not
withstanding any other provision of law
on or after august 15 1973
no funds heretofore or hereafter
appropriated may be obligated or
expended to finance the involvement of
u.s military forces in hostilities in
the air
on the ground or from off the shores of
north vietnam south vietnam laos or
cambodia they made it illegal for the
united states to fulfill the solemn
pledge by which we had
pledged our honor that we would protect
the protocol states of the ceto treaty
from communist aggression
john kennedy's kennedy's
famed inaugural address
said we would pray any price fight any
foe
to preserve the cause of human freedom
after congress did this act north
vietnam's premier friend van dong
reportedly said
the americans won't come back even if we
offered them candy
that totally destroyed deterrence and in
1975 hanoi left one division behind to
protect hanoi and set the rest of their
army behind columns of soviet-made tanks
into laos cambodia and most of it into
south vietnam in an act of conventional
aggression
uh to take over a country by force this
was a uh there's no question this was
against international law a violation of
article two for the eu in charter
and the american people just sat back
and said well maybe the war will be over
after they kill all the people we
promised to help
now ironically this is not something
they came up with in 1973.
from the beginning of the war hanoi's
plan was to use propaganda to influence
the peace movement around the world
which was often controlled by the
soviets uh and to turn the american
people against the war
it is often said the french defeated the
the viet minh defeated the french at
dion vinfou and certainly it is true the
french lost at the
but if you look at the invincio in
military terms
it was not a great defeat for the french
the communists suffered three and a half
times as many fatalities and nearly
twice as many total casualties as did
the french
the pentagon papers reprint some quite
incisive insightful
uh once highly classified cia documents
talking about you know
militarily even if the communists win
it'll probably be a french victory in
the sense that the communists will
suffer so much more
but politically it could have you know
unfathomable consequences what it did
was bring down the linnell government in
paris and bring to power
pierre mendes france the socialist uh
premier who bargained with the
communists and announced i will have
peace in indochina within 30 days or
resign my position
and the viet minh sat back and said you
like the perks of the job the the
the car and the driver and all the nice
women who smile at you well you know
what you're going to sign to keep it and
the french had no interest at all in
looking out for the south vietnamese
they were just a pain in the butt now
that they were no longer going to be
able to exploit them
1947 trung shen then the secretary
general of the indochinese communist
party wrote in the resistance will win
concerning our foreign policy what must
our people do we must isolate the enemy
win more friends
act in such a way that the french people
and the colonial peoples and french
colonies will actively support us and
that all peace-loving forces in the
world will defend us and favor the aims
of our resistance
this is classic leninism
this was their plan in fighting the
americans as well the new york times
reported in 1965
communist hopes for victory turn on
american withdrawal
through exhaustion and in response to
the pressure of public opinion rather
than conventional military success
1963 at the ninth planum of the vietnam
workers party
passed a resolution we must make in make
uh every effort to motivate peace
organizations
we must win the sympathy and support of
the people of the national and
imperialist countries the united states
france england so forth
now i address five myths of many in my
paper and i want to just touch on a few
of them one the statement the state
department lied about aggression from
the north that was the title of a
february 1965 white paper put out by the
state department with all sorts of
photographs of chinese and soviet
equipment that had been captured from
the vietcon
professor kane and lewis
two of the leading anti-war scholars
from from cornell
said the national liberation front is
not hanoi's creation and ample evidence
has been available to uh
convince the state department
that the revival of revolution in the
south was not precipitated by aggression
from the north
after the war hanoi shot this down at
the third party congress even during the
war
uh and they published this in english by
the way a three volume at least two
volumes multi-volume set
leswan
said to ensure the complete success for
the revolutionary struggle in south
vietnam our people there under the
leadership of a marxist-leninist party
of the working class must strive to
bring into being a national united front
and soon thereafter they passed a
resolution to ensure the complete
success of the revolutionary struggle in
south vietnam our people
must bring in a national
national united front and three months
later
by the way i found this in our library
uh hanoi had published it in english and
sent it to all sorts of american college
libraries it did not require great
talent to find this
there were subtle hits that maybe the
vietcong or the national liberation
front in hanoi had something to do with
each other but yeah you had to be really
clever uh to see through this
in may of 1984 vietnam courier a monthly
propaganda journal put out by hanoi
acknowledged they actually had a story
about the legendary ho chi minh trail
that acknowledged the decision in may of
1959 to open the ho chi minh trail and
start sending troops and supplies
through laos and cambodia into south
vietnam to ortho it's government
uh
oh wow yeah you're right
you've been kind okay anyway victory in
vietnam this great book
the official party history acknowledged
uh they made a decision to to to over
the south you know ho chi minh was a
nationalist not a communist sometimes
called the george washington
uh
this is ho selected works writing about
his uh
his reading linen and being so inspired
it was like a religious experience for
him that's a photo of ho in the december
1920 uh this is a socialist party
meeting in paris where the friend these
the french socialist party decided to
become the french communist party ho
then went to moscow for training uh
there here's a photo of him at a
commentary gathering in 1923.
uh the pentagon papers note he was an
old stalin has trained in russia in the
early 20s commander and colleague of
borodin in kentucky chongqing
for a newborn revolutionary power to be
lenient with council revolutionaries is
tanamat to committing suicide they were
brutal in murdering their political
opponents some people say ho was going
to be an asian tito if we just let him
go on in reality when hoe announced he
would wanted to establish diplomatic
relations with all countries
tito was one of the first to offer
recognition ho ignored him he took note
of the offer but did not establish
relations and indeed north vietnam
always considered yugoslavia as a third
world country not a socialist state and
they had been denouncing tito was a spy
for american imperialism for years they
supported the soviet invasion of hungary
of yugoslavia
uh leswan
at the third party congress some modern
revisionists represented by tito where
trumpeting imperialism has changed if
you want to lay bare the aggressive and
bellicose nature of imperialism the
communist parties must necessarily
direct their main blow against
revisionism
we re we we entered vietnam to reimpose
french colonialism simply not true the
the top of a french officer in saigon
escort
cabled his superiors in calcutta the
allied attitude meeting the oss is more
harmful than the viet minh in fact the
sorry the uh
again pentagon papers the u.s
steadfastly refused to assist the french
in their return and i have several other
things here that you'll have to go on
the internet to find or read my paper i
will put them on our website if you
google robert f turner in a week or two
you should find our website and i'm
going to stop right there before
somebody gets out the hook and drags me
away anyway thank you
[Applause]
thank you dr turner at this time i would
like to recognize
15 high school students
guided by their teacher at the
washington international school who came
here to learn about the vietnam world
please give them a hand
mr don boom is a professor of history
and he's teaching vietnam war at the
school thank you
next i would like to bring up
our next speaker dr wing din
who is the president and ceo of bpsos
he was a refugee himself who became a
champion
on refugee issues
he would speak on the the spora
roles in rescuing protecting and
resettling vietnamese refugees please
give him a round of applause thank you
[Applause]
thank you um
when a war ends
human tragedies
usually ensue
however
few of us especially decision makers and
the news media would pay attention to
the aftermath
of a war
after vietnam war
millions of people who sided with
american
allies
to fight for freedom and the reserve
democracy in vietnam suffered
tremendously
today i'd like to tell you the story
of how the vietnamese diaspora we
ourselves
former refugees have reached out and
helped others
in dealing with that aftermath but
before doing so i'd like to recognize
one very special person here lionel
rosenblatt
he was my mentor he was my role model
um
so the the theme of my presentation
today is the healthy hands from the
vietnamese uh
diaspora overseas and most of us
left in 1975 as evacuees
130 thousand yet some vietnamese were
evacuated and picked up
from the ocean by the american seventh
fleet and then later on there both
people i was a boat person myself
leaving vietnam uh late december 1978
and 10 years later i returned to
southeast asia trying to help other more
people coming after after us
the both people saga actually started
very early
by the end of
1975 there were already 15 000 board
people
stranded in different
first assam countries
such as 5 000 in thailand
4 000 already in hong kong almost two
thousand in singapore four thousand
almost in the philippines and uh smaller
numbers in other countries
and then in 1978 there was the first
book people crisis there's a mass exodus
by land and by sea
a hundred and seventy thousand
chinese
from the north were expound from vietnam
and they crossed the border to china few
have heard of these
vietnamese refugees
by land
but by 1979 the united nations high
commissioner for refugees had to convene
the first geneva conference on the both
people because the crisis
countries in the region refuse to take
in more more people
out of that conference there are
agreements
first of all first asylum countries like
thailand indonesia malaysia
including hong kong and and and the
philippines et cetera they agreed to
to give safe harbor to both people at
the same time countries third
countries that is resettlement countries
such as the us led by the us agreed to
take in a lot more refugees under
president carter
um
congress passed the refugee act of 1980
and
very soon about almost two hundred
thousand yen visible people were
reserved under the u.s
and then vietnam agreed to the orderly
departure program that is the way for
vietnamese to live legally
for other countries and that's called
the odp
now
from civil society there's a
number of very valiant
efforts
in different countries in france for
instance
medicine medicine some frontier was
formed later on it received the nobel
peace prize right for its uh
humanitarian work
and medi-sandy hmong was also formed
lesser known but still active to this
day cap anamore in germany
and in the u.s both people sos of which
i am now the ceo and president
they all were founded around 1979
and in the china resource action center
iraq now it has become sierra southeast
asia resource action center
this is this is very classic picture
a rare one
that features dr hussein on the right
who founded co-founded both people as
fast in 1979
and unlike the lost a medical doctor
french medical doctor who founded
medicine dumont and bernard kushner
who founded
medicine south frontier
doctors with the borders we cooperated
we collaborated for many years for 10
years
we work together to send out
ships to the sea to rescue the boat
people
and bvss is a very special organization
it's a hybrid organization in this
picture
you can see the the couple husband and
wife
zumfuk and wu tang tree
uh they were rescued there were both
people
victim of
piracy in this south china sea in the
gulf of thailand the rescue and they
were in the camp in santra refugee camp
and they co-founded both people as well
so our original board directors consist
of two groups one in in san diego
mainly academics in san diego and the
other half were based in a refugee camp
in thailand
and for 10 years
afterwards we have rescued about 3 300
vote people at sea
in collaboration with our other partner
organizations such as medicine dumont
and medicine san francisco no more
now in 1988 10 years later there was a
second bull people crisis
countries in the region became sick and
tired of the both people resettlement
countries reduced the resettlement
quotas and therefore the more and more
people piling up in those countries
in refugee camps so hong kong started to
push back boats and declare a closed
camp policy
both people are no longer considered as
refugees they are now treated as
illegal economic migrants to be deported
to be repatriated in march 1989
the units here well other countries
followed
in the region
oh that is a picture of me
in front of shima one close game in hong
kong and that ship was frustrated by
lino
that was my initiation into this work
thank you liner
the second geneva conference was
convened again by the units in 1989
june
and refugee screening was established
the bad part of this is that countries
of asylum for some conducted refugee
screening and they set a quota only ten
percent and the rest would be
repatriated
uh and there's more and more
pressure to
on the board people who got screened out
is rejected to be repatriated
uh as
a number of resembling countries also
agreed to
sell more both people from the camps and
this is a camp in indonesia a gallon
camp here you can see another fences
with bob white it has turned all the
camps have been turned into prison camps
and
that has left the humanitarian crisis
because of unfair screening we have met
many many
truly
deserving refugees have been denied of
his status and they are facing
eventual fostation to vietnam the
country that they had to flee
had to make a lot of sacrifice to flee
to seek freedom
reduce food rations in the camps very
limited access and reduce access to
social services and children many of
children were denied education
that was to pressure parents to agree to
go back to vietnam
and there's always an increasing threat
of false repatriation and this is a
demonstration in one of the camps uh in
in hong kong
that's chimawakam
and in as our response to that christ
second crisis both people actually
decided to launch
legal assistance for vietnamese some
seekers love us and this is me again
in gallon camp
leading the first team of lawyers and
social workers to visit the camps and
pick up cases
providing them with legal assistance to
defend their right to refugee protection
and we also launched an advocacy policy
advocacy effort
mobilizing the support of memphis
congress luckily
we got the very strong support of
several members congress including
congressman
christopher smith of new jersey
howard berman or tom lentil so and so
forth
mark hatfield
and eventually
the government of the u.s reach an
agreement with other countries in the
region
and the unisa to create and vietnam to
create the rover program which is a
abbreviation of resettlement opportunity
for vietnamese returnees under this
program vietnamese in the camps had to
return to vietnam but then the u.s would
send
interviewing teams to vietnam to
interview them and assess their refugee
status
about 20 000 were later receptive from
vietnam to the u.s
after repatriation to vietnam
now there's still people going leaving
vietnam for other countries after the
the rover program we have thought that
the both people the vietnamese refugee
saga had ended but now
in 2007 there's a trickle a new trick of
vietnamese refugees leaving vietnam for
neighboring countries including cambodia
thailand and some to malaysia and some
to
indonesia and
and even taiwan and
australia
and thousands among them thousands of
hormones
and molten yellow christians
have left reflective myanmar
the
vietnamese refugees in myanmar these
days
and in laos as well
so in 2010
both people as well
again
we set up our legal clinic in bangkok
to help the both people i'm no no longer
both people but the land people coming
out of vietnam so far we have helped
about a thousand to be recognized as
refugees but still
1500
are living in hiding
in
and around bangkok alone
so
the story continues our fight continues
and there are ramifications here
um in the context of this symposium the
question for us all here americans
the media the decision maker is have we
learned a lesson out of vietnam or not
what have happened to our allies after
the war ended did we have an exit
strategy that also included
not just our troops not just our people
but also our allies the family members
i know that we
are now involved in
the middle east
in afghan afghanistan in iraq
have we thought through
before we got involved have you thought
so before we decided to pull out
regardless of the cost of those who left
were left behind because they fought
alongside
american troops
so that is a question for us all to
ponder
so with this i hope that i have
presented the variance and heroic
efforts of the vietnamese
americans and the vietnamese diaspora in
general
in reaching back
and reaching out to help those who are
left behind
or who came out of vietnam
to seek liberty
and human dignity
after us thank you
for our next speaker
um i would like to uh introduce uh dr
win wang han
dr han uh
headed the office of refugee
resettlement at the department of health
and human services or orr
from 2001 to 2005.
he will tell us what role or played in
resettling half a million vietnamese
refugees in the united states
please give him a round of applause
distinguish yes
ladies and gentlemen
first of all i like to
offer my
great
gratitude
appreciation
to the
organizing committee
of the symposium
for the
unique opportunity to be here
to share a few thoughts about the
u.s national
refugee program
beginning from 1975
it is a
major
development
in the aftermath of the vietnam war
and the resettlement of refugees in
america
comes as a result of the generosity
of the american people
as well
as the dedication of countless of
workers and volunteers across
many agencies both in the public
and the private
sector of course we all know that
substantial federal resources
have been committed
to this
national program
to fund services benefits and all kind
of assistance so vital
to the adaptation of refugees
who come here from all over the world
and the mass
evacuation and high sea rescue as you
have just been
introduced to
certainly indicate to you
that
right after the war ended
some 130 000
refugees
and others
from southeast asia
got admitted to this country and the
resettlement of the us began
as a new chapter in our national refugee
program
the
more than two
million south asian refugees and other
new communities
from around the world had already
resettled in the u.s
when president george w bush
administration began
in 2001.
the terrorist attacks
on september 11th
the same year
a forever edge into the american memory
despite the devastation
the vast destruction mountain feelings
of anger and chaos
our nation
show remarkable resilience
and resolve in dealing with this
emergency
ordinary
citizens and their contribution
were the backbone of such resiliency
the next example
was a special gift from a former
vietnamese refugee
mr tandon jung
who donated
2 million dollars
to the american red cross in buffalo new
york
and his generosity
in the hour of national emergency became
a source of pride and appreciation
shared by many vietnamese americans
they
what we
like you to understand is that
immediately
after the 9 11
the office of refugee resettlement or
sometimes which is called orr
immediately
responded to the full scope of the 9th
e-level tragedy by working closely with
the state coordinators voluntary
resettlement agency and community
leaders
to mitigate
the negative repercussions
we
of course say try our best
and
fund it
with extra source of
financial assistance
to the state of new york
to district of columbia to north
northern virginia
to resume the assistance
services to need the refugees affected
by the attacks
and at the national consultation
the following year
our office introduced policy
in terms of priorities
and measured in funding
to address all of the
or at least most of the refugee
emergency
needs
let me say a couple of words about the
orderly departure program or odp
way back in 1979
we all remember that
the odp of 1979
allowed refugee and immigrants to leave
vietnam
for direct resettlement in america and
in other countries around the world
in particular
the vietnamese political prisoners
receive a full range of assistance
services
in terms of adaptation orientation
english as second language
employment training
to become self-sufficient
in this country
and we provide close to one million
dollars
from the office of refugee resettlement
to some 11 states around the country
to help this very special group
from
immigrants from the from vietnam and by
the end of 1994
close to 100 000
former political prisoners and members
of their family had arrived in the u.s
by the ways for those of you who might
not
remember the terminal terminology
when we mentioned about former bollywood
prisoners we're talking about three
issues
free education camp detainees
we also had a very special groups here
and
the children wanted vietnamese mothers
and america american fathers during the
war
they are called americans
and they become a
particular humanitarian concern to the
u.s
and
our nation
welcome them
and
we should know that in the war they
suffer a great deal
they were
ostracized in vietnam
and they survive through deprivation
hardships
with the war ended and the majority of
them managed to survive without proper
care
no education
nor employment potential
so by
1994
the u.s admitted over 70 000
of americans and their families
under the
american american homecoming act of 1988
and that that was a public law and that
was public law number 10202
we also have a program for refugee and
accompanying minors
children with our parents and guardians
found among the
asian refugees and to be sure that we
cover other issues here i like to say
simply that
by 1994
the u.s received ontario close to 11 000
of these vulnerable children and we
placed them in foster care
facility in some 14 states
and of course many of them
they were reunited with their families
and they also were
emancipated
when they reached the age of
emancipation
at the age of 18 or so in most of the
state
we also have other special populations
that the u.s deeply care for
they include
the mountaineers from vietnam
the lost boys of sudan
the hmong and others
there was a group of
children
called unaccompanied alien children
they are not
refugees
actually
the unaccompanied
alien children
was transferred to us a minute
in
2000 2003
from the department of homeland security
or ins
is one of these divisions there
very quickly i like to say that
throughout the u.s national program we
also have major consultation by congress
headed by
high level officials to deal with all
issues such as admission level
budgetary concern
and all of the commitments from other
agencies i'd like to say a few words
about the legacy of the vietnamese in
america
as you know since 1975
by the time president bush was in office
three decades or so we built very
vibrant communities across the land
we was we are so honored to see so many
of our engineers
physicians
lawyers and so on participating in full
range of professional careers
and we also do well as far as our second
generation children is concerned in
eurovision college on together we have
very vibrant vietnamese community and
that is the legacy of the vietnamese in
america
for the um
young generation
and we we are very delighted to see a
group of young
students here today we certainly think
that um
as you will recall
not too long ago there was a famous um
writer economist by the way
by the name
who said this
and i quote
to be
fair to the author
the direct goat is this
no past experience
however rich
no historical research
however thorough
can save the living generation
the creative task of finding their own
answer and shaping their own future
and thank you so much
thank you dr nguyen
now um before i bring up the next guest
i want everybody do me a favor i'm
looking at the audience and i think the
aftermath of lunch is taking effect so
let everybody just get up for like 30
seconds to stretch please
because we don't want to lose half of
you in the next 30 minutes so everybody
says stretch for me for a minute
that's right i see a lot of smiles and
stretching there he goes all those eyes
are open now thank you
okay
yeah it seems like you guys are enjoying
it uh too much so i think we need
everybody settle down a little bit here
see now now all the eyes are open we're
all fresh we just came here right
okay
all right let's get back to the program
i need everybody's attention please
i know we're all awake and we're we want
to talk to everybody right now but we
needed to convey reconvene so thank you
everybody for doing that uh i think we
all needed it
so
so next i will bring up our next speaker
uh who
who is dr tavang dai
who's the former lecturer and research
associate of harvard law school
attorney of law
and he will be discussing the lessons
learned from the vietnam war please give
him a round of applause thank you
hello and thanks to everybody and
especially
the committee in the organizing
committee
today i am giving the topic of lessons
from the vietnam war
at the end of the
presentation
of the of the older generation
speakers
the younger speakers come after
so i have the impression the organizer
wants me to
have some kind of summation
like in a court of law for the jury
of this audience and the world to see
what the grown-ups are going to
to say in a nutshell in my some
summation here but in my summation i
also mentioned
something for the next
the younger generation which is
reconciliation after the war
i guess you guys
want that and no more
grievances
at least
that your future
so
because of that i'm going to
go very rapidly
over five lessons
i see
you may
see that my
lessons presented seem to already been
talked about in the previous papers
because this is the submissions of all
the lessons in the kind of bull-eye
views of the vietnam war
because of that
i may have given me the burden of
talking too much so i'm going to
talk in a very concise language and
rapidly
by a machine gun if i have to
and i i want the
the
clock to remind me so i my i put on my
own clock
50-minute star
first lesson
changing national interest in vietnam
or led to drastic change in the nature
of the war civil war
becoming internationalized or
in the strategy accompanying
it
vietnam war began as a
first uh as a civil war then became
international war by proxy promoted by
the big powers of the two cold war
blocks
beginning in 1946
the communist leaders in vietnam
under
the
second-ranked leaders
like ominja
begin to start
wai ho chiming was in fontainebleau in
france for the conference start the
assassination
campaign against the nationalists
destroying the headquarters and the
hinterland bases
later the civil war rapidly become
internationalized
by proxy because
intervention of france great britain and
the republic of china
france troops were brought back to no
vienna by the british
by the british
who was there to disarm the japanese
was held to occupy north vietnam by the
republic of china armed forces
but there also to disarm the japanese
the united states vessel
please pay attention the united vessel
brought the french expeditionary forces
to hanoi and hai haifa
to help the france to reoccupy
in china
in contrary to president roosevelt wish
to get rid of the french president in
indochina
but in
following the new policy of president
truman to help the france
because the cold war in europe already
developed
in 1954 the american replaced the french
in
helping holding him
the the civil war at that time become
more full fully civil because the two
countries then
with separate territories separate
government
and population but at the same time it
also become more internationalized
because less one said we find alpha is
the fight for the soviet union and china
and south vietnam was assigned the role
of the bulwark of the free world
in 1973 the united states star
talking with china in the nixon trip in
beijing
the american no more have
serious national interest
in vietnam
so
the abundance of vietnam
made concession at the paris peace of
course
agreeing to a leopard skin ceasefire in
south vietnam
left no vietnamese troops inside vietnam
jeopardizing the
south survival
only
wishing to bring the american troops and
prisoner home
in 1975 in april kissinger hit from
congress
the promise of president nixon to come
to hell
presidential with b-52 bombing
or arms ed
and later only the congress and
president for talk only about evacuation
of the americans from vietnam and the
one in vietnam from that point on is
is a civil war fought by south vietnam
alone
when president hill resigned in april
1975
the
champion home and the jungle main
government tried to negotiate with the
northern
side by saying we want to negotiate with
the vietnamese brothers
hopefully
but they don't the law do not consider
the south and the brothers
and they rushed to saigon to capture
the city and force unconditional
surrender to
the zhiyun government government
but i must say we still have to thank
the united states for not abandoning the
flood of refugees coming out of south
vietnam
and bringing them halfway around the
world never before halfway around the
world to the united states
but another lesson for a small country
is
small countries should never trust the
big power
who has abandoned
the mission of protecting the small
power and should always look for a
separate peace negotiation
with the other side
as for the united states
the lesson is should never enter a land
war in asia
where
they
fire ten thousand years or a small
situation threatened
and then got stuck there without
an
honorable exit
there should always be an existing
strategy from a war like
third thompson in malaysia
advise
the vietnamese later
second lesson
a negotiated peace must end the war
world cannot begin forever that's why i
blame president till
for being unwilling to agree to the
ninth
1970
to realize the 1973
ceasefire agreement by agreeing to
running the
elections
for vietnam and he always talked about
boncom
for news no negotiation no accommodation
with the communities there's a wrong
policy
previously president jim
has more enlightenment in this respect
he
talked about
sending
uh mr new
to the plateau to talk to mr farm home
secretly
about how to solve the problem
of uh
of of the war he also
but he made the wrong mistake of not
agreeing
to the
running of the election in 1956
president trio
was advised by dr
who was advised by he
professor of economics or not the
university of virginia
that vietnam should have a separate
peace
negotiation with north vietnam
and dr hung advised to tell to do that
until in the 1971 election speech
mentions
some attempt to negotiation but then he
checked with the americans the americans
said too late and so he
withdrew
in 1975 right before the takeover
the delegate from the national
liberation front proposed to generate
gundog to tell mr till take them in the
in the coalition government so
to
to get rid of the control of the
non-vietnamese in the front
mr tell us to talk to the americans
americans say
uh too late also too late
so the lesson is the authority to settle
the war should be left with the
party that fought the war on the ground
not to the big power that have abandoned
the theater
and veto on it that's the lesson i would
propose which is a second lesson
a separatist peace without vietnam
despite the americans and
make a fair complete
before the americans
the third lesson is uh
i have seven more minutes
the third lesson is
why should we refer to the people
as ultimate arbiter because modern war
drags the whole population in
then the whole population have to
support the war in order to win
there are two basic mistakes about this
aspect the first was
the decision to escalate the war
gradually what they called in one hand
study political side in
virginia
university of virginia they said gradual
deterrence which is increase it a little
bit at the time
that is bad that's the strategy should
be to win a rapid victory in a few
months with overwhelming power to avoid
tearing out the american and the
vietnamese public
there there was a general sin glove
who's talked about the seven days war
seven days only in president bush
father
has launched the
the governor in 30 days only and he won
victoriously
the
second mistake was there should always
be a constitutional process of
declaration of war by congress without
declaration of war
the congress always say oh now
the war
powers resolution we take back your
power from the president and the prison
has nothing to do
on the vietnamese communist side they
understand better the power of the
people in war
they're talking about people war people
army
liberal
general jabs wrote his book
with the same title
the
democratic
regime has been developed in republic of
south vietnam somehow
with the election of the constitutional
assembly with the constitution in 1967
the election of the two houses
in 1967 so and then the election of the
half of the senate in 1970
all with the enthusiastic
participation
of the people or on other religious all
kinds of oppositional releases and
political force
this democratic
democratizing activity has the
encouragement
of ambassador ellis banker
he mentioned
one civilian leader that could be
the
the helper
for winning the war professor
ryan van bong law professor also
director of the national institute
administration
who has high
high following among the administrative
apparatus
ambassador called him
the the household name in sauvignon
but messenger came to saigon to ask
president hill to name him
premier prime minister
the next day the communists assassinate
him
with a bomb under his car
so the communists know
the power of the popular support
the full
lesson uh
one should end with reunifica uh
reconciliation this is for the next
younger generation right here
the older generation like us we may have
resentment
about really chicken scam
relaxation scams that have
initiated in 1975 the communists by the
communists who did not have the
enlightened
generous
generosity
of lincoln advised after civil war
abiding the nation wounds
caring for the soldiers in their widow
and orphan to achieve a just and lasting
peace the reason was a lot it was thrown
into reading
camp with the painful result of roon
health
social dislocation
painful reason reassessment to life
after
release
and the resentment continue on
also vietnam now has a policy of
inviting the oversee veterans to come
back
travel
investment
advising national government but the
resentment is still there and when the
diplomats go around
abroad they are still bull
or thrown rotten eggs in their face
so the communists had better learn the
lesson of reconciliation
of manson mandela
reconciliation
on the two sides
and one important measure is to let the
south vietnamese mourned for their death
in the binhoa cemetery and not trying to
obliterate it
faith lesson
the
presidential leadership
of
zmtl and even johnson
is to be considered
a professor of political science
and miller at dartmouth college thing
the
overthrows here may be responsible for
the rapid downfall of south vietnam i
disagree
because president jim
died 12 years before 1975 his debt could
not have influenced the ultimate outcome
in 1975 which was a result of the brute
force exercise by the invading
vietnamese troop not because there is a
light of popular leader
anyway mr ziam is not a popular leader
with the buddhist crisis
that create
illegitimacy and ruin his rule and even
because he is dead
the the reason why the
sauvignon was lost in 1970 was the the
mistake of president johnson introducing
combat troops
to to vietnam to find the vietnamese war
let the vietnamese find their own wars
and the u.s should only advise and give
weapons
i see i would like to have 30 certain
more
so that president johnson mr leadership
presidential mistake was being very
selfish
issuing
uh
confusing and inconsistent order at the
last minute in 1975
withdrawing from the mainland the
central highland and huayindana
he was so selfish mistrustful
and and fearful of his subordinates that
professor win wakui my colleagues that
he will shake hand with his
with others and then at night time he
come back he looked at his hand
and wonder whether he still has five
fingers
the leadership of south vietnam
including the two presidents and the
allegiance of vietnam already achieved
remarkable nation successes
and one of them is
the outstanding
land reform lend to the taylor program
much more successful than the law
and then other
administrative
economic social economic education and
real reforms
and in a foreign relation i already
mentioned this morning
the
the struggle
here in new york circle in the paracel
island to assert national sovereignty
which vietnam now have to accept it is a
very good
thing they inherit as a successful state
to to vindicate vietnamese sovereignty
over this archipelago
thank you
thank you dr
next i would like to introduce our
discussant
mr frank snap
mr frank snap was a cia officer in
vietnam and afterwards wrote uh what is
probably still the definitive account of
the american evacuation of saigon in
april of 1975
uh
titled decent interval
mr mr snap will summarize the main
points of the four papers and make some
remarks on his own
thank you please give him a round of
applause
what i'm going to do first
is give my own ideas because i have seen
many of them
glossed over
in the discussions thus far
i want to start out by saying we covered
the vietnam war and i'm talking about
the cia almost better than any other war
imaginable we had
one of the best agents his real name is
planted inside the communist command and
from
literally
1969 when the cia took control of him
till the end
he provided us with advance warning of
every major
communist decision
including their unwillingness
to agree to
a negotiated settlement at the end
but
we lacked
critical intelligence on one major
aspect of the war
it was not until
noel
took over in cambodia that we realized
that nearly 80 percent of the supplies
destined for communist forces in the
saigon area and the delter
were coming in through sihanakville
folks what that means is
that the bombing of the ho chi minh
trail system
was useless
the stemming the flow of material into
the saigon area
and the delta
second point that's been overlooked
espionage by the enemy
one of my colleagues sam adams
found by looking at evidence drawn from
the
village and hamlet level
sources
that the communists had at least 30 000
potential spies buried inside
the south vietnamese regime
we now know from subsequent publications
out of hanoi
that they had three people
possibly three inside the joint general
staff
that gave them advance warning of
president tu's critical decisions
including his decision to withdraw from
the highlands
in march wow
wow
and they hadn't
their track record was pretty good
before then
that strategic hamlet program in the
early 1960s rufus phillips has told you
how wonderfully we did
but
siem's
principal
administrator for the strategic hamlets
program was a communist
spy so what he did was to move
strategic hamlets into
insecure territory where they were
picked off one by one
nearly a decade later two's primary
political
adviser was a communist spy
that's breathtaking
breathtaking
and finally the
the very overlooked
item
that helped decide
the end of the war the way it happened
corruption
my friend lionel rosenblatt
asked about it in the previous session
we don't have to wonder how bad it was
major general
gwen van hewe
wrote a report
for the vice president's office
in 1972 at the height of the offensive
which indicated
that corruption had penetrated and
compromised almost every
every
south vietnamese bureaucracy
from the
passport service
to the
military security service
folks
when you have that kind of record it
doesn't matter
if you
can't do a very good job
with persuading the american public
so
now
our friend mr butler
professor butler tells us
congress
sold the south vietnamese out congress
lost the war nonsense
deputy secretary of defense clements
in may or june july of 1973
proposed that aid to south vietnam be
cut back because the ceasefire agreement
it was in congress that came up with the
idea it was clements
and then came the yom kippur war
and the oil embargo which drove up
prices inside south vietnam on
on almost everything by 69 percent
and because of the weapons we've given
to israel during the war to keep them
supplied we didn't have reserves to give
to south vietnam so the picture is a
little bit more complicated
and it is a little troubling
to see at this late date when all of
this material is available
people continue to hammer hammer away on
melvin laird's nonsense
about congress having sold out the south
vietnamese they had spies everywhere
mr tang
asked
did we have an extra strategy yes we did
but it was a cynical non-starter
i estimated
that we should be
evacuating
a million vietnamese
turn that over to the ambassador
it went to
the guyler the commander-in-chief of the
pacific
now the only way to evacuate a million
vietnamese
was by sending him down the road to vang
tao
to be lifted off the beaches
that was the exit strategy
but it was cynical
because
it wouldn't work the communists could
sever that highway with a sapper squad
so all the talk of our having
contingency plans for a major evacuation
was a nonsense
mr han and mr tung
talked about
a horrible
refugee situation
and i can only
extend to them
my
profoundest respect
for having put an effort into this it
took the united states a little while to
get up to speed
that's one of the reasons i wrote my
book and published it
in
1978
right after the war because i was trying
to focus
attention
on our obligation to the south
vietnamese we left behind
that's it
[Applause]
next i'd like to introduce our moderator
dr
dong vieque chairman of the
international institute for vietnam
and a visiting scholar at the columbus
school of law at the catholic university
of america
dr was
a persistent critic of the current
government of vietnam on human rights
grounds and spent many years in
vietnamese prison on that account
he is the recipient of the number of
human rights awards including the
international press freedom award of the
committee to protect journalists
and the robert f kennedy human rights
award
dr hart will oversee the questions and
answers for this period time thank you
please give him a
round of applause
thank you mr lee
we have been listening to five speakers
continuously
so i think all of you are very tired of
listening
so now it's time for you to speak up
and question
you have only one minute for
one person because you have many i think
many questions
and if you want to
raise the question to any particular
specific speaker please
pick up the names or the title of his
pics
so please
let's begin
anyone who wants to
bring up
questions
just stand up over there okay please
thank you my name is
something about yourself just you name
it
my name is jeannie wen with voice of
vietnamese americans
my question is to mr frank snap thank
you for the decent interval
so we learned that the lesson
came from intelligence spy
leadership
i would like to ask you also
about the negotiation
all the agreements and the international
law
can we just the other side who we
talked to
you know kissinger talked to children
life and the paris agreement was mid
sign
president hill did not want to sign it
but he was made having to cite it
and look at today what happened in the
south china sea
in the pacific ocean
where china has been expanding with
chinese expansionism
what would you think
the lessons can apply now can we trust
the communist
agreement and the way the negotiating
the way
should we trust them and shoot our u.s
people and president
just
the communist that's time thank you
okay thank you
first part of the question
kissinger kept
secret from even the cia the progress of
his negotiations the way we learned
about them
was through reporting from our best
agent inside the communist command you
get that
it made a loop
from paris back to tainan province then
to
us that's not a good way to get
intelligence on
what's going on in paris
the
smp yeah okay you want to have some
scenery
is it
did not want to sign
i i i support mr taylor
in transitions
during the war or peace negotiation like
that because
kissinger negotiates
an agreement that almost
matching the the other side demands
for many years so he has a legitimate
nationalist
reason to resist
his resist so much that when kissinger
came to vietnam he
tried to
proceed
thinking he can proceed mr taylor by uh
say saying that i introduce you mr nya
to the nice girls
somewhere so you think you can buy mr
nyan but mr ma resists that too
and until we finally have to give up to
sign because there was an excellent
nixon letter
transmitted to mr taylor saying that uh
if you don't know sign or agree 30
seconds
we are afraid that uh
there may be
events like 1963 implying murder
so he was scared and he told dr
that anytime he wanted to
discuss something he would go to the
balcony of the independence like this
with doctor hung next to him to talk
out to the garden because he's afraid of
the cia listening in the back wall over
there
so he's so scared of the americans
attempted murder
design
thank you last time
i will shift from
here to there please
should we continue to talk a negotiation
that's the main part that's your
question risk please because we have
many many questions please but my
question wasn't answered yet sir
it was answered by me no
i'm asking should we continue to
negotiate and you can ask somebody later
but now you have to that was my first
question personally it hasn't been
answered please
you can ask questions okay thank you
so
i'm
very excited by uh
by what
mr frank snap
said because since i was a child um
i i love very much a kind of spy novels
yeah
but
now in this symposium you talk about cia
and
you you you said that
vietnamese communists they succeeded in
introducing
their spy in the south the vietnam
government
and
my question is why uh the united states
uh okay cia
and uh american government in general or
south vietnam government
did not
do the same thing my
my opinion is that
because
uh
vietnamese communists that they fought
uh
the united states
and
in
the south they use just vietnamese yeah
as spy
but the united states basically vietnam
war is a an american war and so
cia you you cannot uh use an uh like a
white uh american people to come in in
in the north
vietnam government but the south vietnam
uh uh i think and you analyze them uh
many times that that a
very corrupt government important
government and is that case in the
united states i'm going to ask you to
stop please what's your question please
so my question so i i would like to ask
mr franken snap
to provide with a um
explanation why the united states
uh didn't succeed in
port spy
uh uh in in in in um high level of
vietnamese uh communist leadership
during vietnam we did we thank you i
just explained that we we had a we had a
spy inside cosmic the central office for
south vietnam that's the major communist
headquarters for the saigon area and the
delta
we had a spy inside that
that entity and i was initially involved
in vetting him in 1970 i remained a
primary exponent of his
i believe he was
just pure gold and he was
he provided us with advance warning he
said
in april
on april 8 1975
the communists are going to take saigon
by the end
of april early may
and most importantly he said all the
talk of a negotiated settlement is just
a smoke screen to throw the united
states off balance despite that
the ambassador the french
my ci station chief all pursued
this
shamira of a negotiated settlement
despite the fact that our agent
said it was a smoke screen and it was
thank you thank you
please
before you ask the next question
i like to make a suggestion anybody
asking a question please make it defined
and focus please
thank you
please this time
my name is alvin kam thank you for all
the speakers for having tried to help
south vietnam i was among the victims of
the tech attacked
i was at the last year at the recent
jacuzzi in saigon
and a missile was landed on my principal
desk because our school was across the
street from the presidential palace the
missiles was meant for the palace
my school was interrupted but uh just
going back today i wish to acknowledge
professor turner and mr frank's death
for having raised something very heart
feeling to me which is the sense of
abandon i mean being a christian i try
to live the spirit unconditional love
and forgiveness but i have to tell you
i'm still very hurt by the sense of
betrayal
and that sense of abandonment by the
american
government has sent millions of
vietnamese into exodus and also in some
cases death so my question to all the
speakers
how can the vietnamese diaspora help our
brothers and sisters in vietnam to break
the yoke of communist
oppression to build a government for
which human rights religious freedom and
environmental justice matter thank you
thank you
maybe down the town you want first to
answer that question
well i believe that the vietnamese
diaspora can play a very important role
and critical role
first of all we can do advocacy
because we are now citizens of the free
world
we have influence over governments our
own government here as well
secondly
we have over the years over the past
many decades
by thriving in this country by building
communities we have accumulated a lot of
skills
organizing and organizational skills
that we can pass on the viet people in
vietnam so for the past
10 years we have been building capacity
for different religious and indigenous
communities in vietnam through a very
special kind of hybrid organization just
like bpsos where some members
organization
belong to that community in vietnam the
core members of that company in vietnam
and other members of the same
association belongs to the vietnamese
diaspora so together we form civil
society organizations embedded in each
community it has been working so far
any other speaker wants to answer the
question please
[Music]
education
i think that's the key part there are so
many americans of vietnamese ancestry
you're going back
take
the federalist papers take the writings
of jefferson take things to teach people
the rule of law
and spread the message that there is an
opportunity for some young man or woman
to be vietnam's real george washington
to to push for a free society with
individual rights with limited
government
uh and and have the people understand
why that's important why when you get
arrested you should have a judge who is
not getting orders from the party but is
getting orders from a jury of your peers
i think that message will be very
popular and i think ultimately somebody
will rise up and the the more
demand there is for this the more
likelihood that the party will
ultimately realize
you know hey communism is dead around
the world
uh
maybe the answer is even for a member of
the party to be that george washington i
don't care how it happens but for it to
happen the people have to have the
knowledge of what the alternative is to
realize how much better things are
outside vietnam although the economy
certainly has improved
with the free market opportunities
they've got but but i think the the
single most important thing is education
please you want to answer
i want to add this for the
benefit of the younger generations
if
even we discuss about the past war we
can have hope in the future because the
people in vietnam now are the are the
most
pro-american people in the world i can
certify to that with my several
seven on eight trips to vietnam to
attend conference i came back not as
some tourist countering to the
government but as an invitee to attend
conferences and i talked to the people
to to the to the
uh sickle driver or this
taxi driver and they are very
pro-american so
the the hope is always there
nobody like the chinese so
so we have hoped that
the relationship
would come to reconciliation and for the
vietnamese diaspora i would say that you
should have some generosity to forget
about
the
the past crime of the regime those
crimes was committed by the
the 70 or 80 years old in 1975 the new
generation was not even born after the
75
ending of the war so you talk to the
people of vietnam not to the government
of vietnam and that is the best hope for
reconciliation
thank you now turn to this side please
this question is to
dr professor thai
on your previous speech
i don't like the title doctor professor
in vietnam in vietnam the youth
is it's a tautology not too much title
just dr thai or professor thai or mr
thai is okay
i'm not the vain like the people in
vietnam
thank you
uh
you give us particularly to the young
generation
a very important lesson
it's about reconciliation and you have
been repeating it many times
my question to you
is
in order to help the young
generation to fully understand
your lesson
so that they can carry on
their future
important role
to bring back
the democracy freedom or prosperity to
vietnam
they must understand clearly what you
mean by reconciliation
so my question to you is
if you take into account
of
the
what the
vietnamese communist did before 75
by
killing thousands of people
in
1954 when they said
i got your point i got your point can i
get the landing form
okay i got your point also big offensive
in huey okay i i was in hue i got an
important let me answer you now finish
my question
and also shorten your question after
75
they put thousands of
the all-time
southern military person
and
right now
they are
they don't consolidate
coincide with their own people
against the invasion of communism
by
put them in prison
even
the
u.s citizen
came to vietnam and support the
demonstration
they beating them up
so
the reconsideration
is based on the will of two parties
to come to the compromise
how can the consolidation
happen
if another one
like this morning
speech saying that they try
to take all over the vietnam and also in
the china by all means and also
sacrifice
the human life of their own sawyers and
also their own people
how if you take into that factor
can you still afford to say can you
reaffirm your purpose let me forget what
i'm going to say let me answer you okay
please please please
okay
yeah the vietnamese you are talking to
as a younger generation is a
young
vietnamese generation not the
obdurate stop-on
leaders that are going to the grave very
soon
and you talk to the younger generation
the generation that hope the american to
come back so much that they invent a
story that the turtles or top toys
in the whole one game emerged with two
chinese characters
on on the back of it that means
i mean hawks we mean
talk to us monkey but
playing on the world meekwa means the
americans are coming
because they hope so much for the
american coming before
[Music]
normalization of relation
and you talk to a younger nation you
talk as
as people who already won the peace you
want the peace you don't you may lost
the war but you want the peace because
the vietnamese society now
break to have foreign investment trade
with the
biggest market in the united states uh
hope to send their children here to
education even the highest officials try
to buy houses to send their children
here so you want the peace and i
remember i mentioned to the
vietnamese american conference in hawaii
in 1994
93 before even lifting the virgo
i flatter the vietnamese government a
little bit i said ho chi minh said
all men are created equal and
the proceeds of happiness and so on
right so i said we vietnamese abroad
would come back to vietnam build the
school
build
the the the
the
road and develop vietnam to make the
vietnamese people unhappy
like ho chi minh said in his declaration
of independence immediately after that
the deputy
foreign minister of vietnam
came to the podium and said
i just heard someone say something very
moving
his move on my
persuasion of the american delegation
come back to vietnam and
as a victor in peace to be to build up
the school the road
and develop vietnam
after that we sent a letter to president
clinton 1994 he left the embargo
so i would say to talk to them
as the victor in peace
but in with modesty not arrogance okay
thank you uh dr thai
uh
please yeah
um and again i would like to mention
please keep your questions short and
defined since we don't have that much
time available thank you
i just wanted to thank dr tang for
singling me out uh
i think that he has done an incredible
herculean job of
inventing advocacy by the diaspora he
was in the lead throughout there are two
figures that should be mentioned for the
record though that that came way before
and that's
before anybody came out of vietnam that
was julia taft who
stayed by the vietnamese issue even when
it was unpopular
and uh afterwards
a very unsung hero by the name of shep
loman whom some of you know by his wife
theoploman without shep many of the
programs outlined earlier today would
not have existed so they need to be
added for the record and finally
young that then young frank snap's book
played a key role we used it to the
utmost to get support for picking up the
refugee program when it had faltered the
initial battles we had were very i must
tell you very
much biased against the vietnamese south
vietnamese they were losers
they were asians who wouldn't adjust to
this country we had to really wrestle
with congress in particular to get any
authority and that's why it didn't come
until april
15th perhaps of that year we had no
authority to admit any vietnamese
finally we got it and things began to
happen but that was the biggest single
reason that we didn't have a program
until the very end was that congress
didn't give a damn thank you
[Applause]
give me about 30 seconds just to clarify
something frank said because it's not
really a debate frank said that i was
ridiculous when i were absurd or
something when i said that congress was
the villain because they cut off aid
they did cut off aid i worked in the
senate during the final years i listened
as the executive branch begged us for
money somebody in the pentagon may well
have said we don't need more money but
the official request from president ford
was we need more money but more
importantly he doesn't mention
in in may of 1973 congress passed a law
making it illegal for u.s troops to come
back in any way to help no bombing no
nothing and that totally undermined us
and that's when fam van dog said they
won't come back even if we offer them
candy so i stand by my original comment
frank and i can argue this later but
thanks
thank you
yes
yes uh my question is for dr turner um
in
reference to your comments that congress
lost the war and that bill colby had
expressed the view of the cia that the
war is winnable um as a historian what
weight do you give to the views of those
in the intelligence community like
george sarah's
state department sam adams bobby layton
and many others who exposed many lives
that had been told and and what weight
do you give to the fact that when
congress and the senate foreign
relations committee realized after
august 1974 in the gulf and tonkin
resolution that they've been lied to
that that started all the other
things that happened in congress up to
the final lies when henry kissinger had
told the south vietnamese that uh we
would come back and force if the
the north vietnamese
invaded do you wish we had a lot more
time for this because i don't think
there were any lies in what you said
lbj did not lie when he asked for
congressional support lbj was under
tremendous pressure from congress to do
more in vietnam he got a report that on
the 2nd of august 1964
the
uss maddox had been attacked by north
vietnamese boats though in [ __ ] told
robert mcnamara when mcnamara went to
vietnam in 1998 yes that attack occurred
there is some doubt about the second
attack i actually doubt it happened on
august 4th but i have spoken to several
people who were on the maddox
and see turner joy
who tell me they are certain the attacks
occurred now we don't have time to go
into this but this was not a matter of
anybody lying to anybody nor did
kissinger or nixon lie to chew they
thought that if you know they were going
to the agreement was flawed
but we had just kicked the butt out of
north korea of north vietnam in in the
linebacker 2 december bombing and
the game was
if hanoi violates the agreement we'll
send the b-52s back
and it was only when congress made that
illegal that it was impossible to
fulfill those promises but but but nixon
and kissinger had no idea that congress
was going to cut off funds now there are
a lot of people that have different
views about vienna vietnam between 68
and 75 i was in 42 out of 44 provinces i
can tell you what i saw and the
difference especially in the delta was
incredible the south vietnam was winning
the vc were almost non-existent the
north vietnamese were back in the
background
uh if i carried a weapon with me when i
drove from saigon into the delta uh it
was not locked and loaded uh i i i felt
more fear walking through parts of
washington dc after 9 pm than i did
driving through the delta things were
much better
bill colby was a good friend he used to
come down every year to speak to my
vietnam seminar he called he wrote a
book called lost victory several friends
of mine douglas pike was there doing
several times during the war uh bob
sorley is one of the top historians on
this uh a lot of us feel that that we
were winning the war and a number of
former north vietnamese and viet
vietcong officials
uh
uh colonel boyten
said that you had us on the ropes you
could have finished this off uh uh you
know so you know my own sense is that
we were winning the war
until congress came in and told hanoi we
promise we won't come back so you can do
whatever you want and then congress cut
off aid and i can tell you i worked with
the foreign relations committee during
the final few years of the war
the administration was begging us for
money to keep vietnam going and the
committee was saying no more money they
gave us some but not very much
next
next question please
my question is from mr
frank snap
mr snap
i read your books 40 years ago the
descending room
and today i see you in person
talking about the intelligence and your
own
in vietnam
my first question is that
did the cia involved
into the good data
leading to assassination of the
presidential museum
the second question is that
the cia in vietnam
knows so much
about
the
vietnam
infiltration into the vietnamese
government in vietnam
did you
share
these intelligence to the vietnamese
authority at that time
let me ask answer the second question
first
okay
let me ask the answer the
the second question first the um
we didn't tell the south vietnamese that
we suspected they were riddled with
spies
like swiss cheese
because they were whittled with spies
like swiss cheese
uh that was one of the great
uh anomalies
we couldn't share intelligence with our
allies
because we were so suspicious of them
uh it and this is not to comment on the
reliability of your the average south
vietnamese soldier leader what have you
the communists have simply been very
successful
in inserting their people
inside
the government's military and political
bureaucracies
that was the problem the
on a larger point
um
we
[Music]
we um
i would say the the single intelligence
failure that lost the war was there a
failure to understand the vietnamese
to really spend time making them
intelligence target
the
macv
and defense attaches office
were under orders not to collect
intelligence against the south
vietnamese
we couldn't spy on our allies
and what that meant was we were the last
to know when they were screwing up
when they were when morale was toppling
it was a horrible situation
and
one of my jobs was to brief the south
vietnamese police
on what we knew of communist plans
and it was one of the most difficult
tasks i had because i couldn't tell them
what we were getting from our primary
agent inside the communist
command
now it so happened
this had originally been a joint
operation with the south vietnamese
police so they
probably knew what we were getting from
this spy
but
it was a very difficult situation
our ability to share information with
the south vietnamese
so
you you answer the second question how
about the first question
which one is that first one
that was before my time but i can tell
you because
bill colby was
my father's very good friend at columbia
that colby
was very concerned that we not repeat
that
and it was a major consideration of his
during the final days of the war he kept
saying don't do anything to overthrow
two don't do it even though that might
bring peace don't do it
that's why when president when
ambassador martin went to two
he used the soft cell he didn't say get
the heck out and the americans are gonna
boot you out he said well if you're a
patriot
you will sacrifice yourself for the
country and that actually worked
so i'm answering your question
indirectly but it was the the fear of
another xem
coup
that dictated much of u.s intelligence
policy in vietnam
thank you can i say something to this
yeah
i know from the inside the negotiation
between france the united states and the
zombie main government at the last
moment
i was escaping five days before the
downfall
but to do one but i talked to my
brother-in-law
bhutan won minister of defense in the
young women government and he told me
in the last part of april
that ambassador marion
already have the approval
of the american ambassador to talk to
the other side so they can arrange if
u.s not primarily at least france with
the remaining influence
arranged for a
interregnum period so that the
vietnamese
government can be in place for a while
the soviet union can be in place forward
for those population strata that are
entire communists can move out of south
vietnam live from north vietnam to south
vietnam in a hundred that the hundred
days into regular that's the purpose of
the zone one main government
the humanitarian purpose they know they
are going to lose a war but they have
the wars from the ambassador of farms
and
and
working
closely with the american ambassador at
that time he's already washed his hands
off the whole thing because washington
did not approve of his intervention
so
it is a very good
well-intentioned
purpose of the zoom one main government
to save saigon from being destroyed to
to
to
uh destroy totally okay thank you
please
so this question is directed at mr snap
again i'm sorry for the double header on
questions um
so we just recently in mr boehm's class
we just recently learned a lot more
about the cia's actions in
a lot of different places like italy
iran
uh guatemala and even a little bit in
cuba so i was wondering
did was there any attempt to try and use
the cia in an active role like it was
used in those
past uh attempts or was it just being
used as basic espionage ambassador
martin had previously been ambassador
to italy
and so he used
the kind of techniques that we used in
vietnam the what what the important
thing here
is to understand
that when the ci begins meddling
in a government and that certainly
happened in two's re-election day out of
1971 the cia becomes a stakeholder
in the event
and that means it cannot honestly assess
the purpose or the effectiveness of that
intervention
i i could go on and on and on about the
problems
we had in vietnam
and these problems went to the heart of
what we knew and whether we knew enough
about the south vietnamese to give them
an even chance
thanks
hi i'll try to make this brief i'm a
young vietnamese american i grew up in
united states i you know was born after
the war
i am on the side of the victims the
victims of reeducation camp the boat
people the victims of human rights
violations i'm with the people of
vietnam so how can we work with vietnam
when the current government of vietnam
do not respect its own people
secondly i
felt that the media misrepresented the
south vietnam because i was working on a
picture of general wing of long and i
interviewed people who worked directly
with him and evidently jenna wong was a
good general he was not corrupted as
we've been portraying
a lot of the vietnamese leaders and
there is a memorial in california that
say there are thousands of south
vietnamese committed suicide because
they refuse
to surrender to communism
no one talked about that
and
so
you know a lot of us here have major
ptsd from the war so how can we help
them heal in order to move a step
forward and how can we work with vietnam
when the vietnamese government
currently is abusing his own people
thank you
anyone
any one of the speakers want to answer
that please
yeah i'm really glad you asked those
questions uh and uh
several things going on noah
general alone actually i had his
daughter as a student 20 probably 30
years ago
when she was an undergraduate and i
talked about vietnam and my u.s foreign
policy class
i knew a number of people in vietnam who
knew him and every one of them had the
greatest respect for him he was was not
corrupt he was incredibly courageous he
would lead as a general would lead squad
size operations to attack vc
uh and he had all sorts of emotional
reasons for shooting the bound vc
terrorists in the head uh eddie adams
captured won the pulitzer prize for the
photograph of of the shooting
now
i'm an international lawyer i teach law
of armed conflict that was a war crime
there's no question about it
but
adams actually
before he died after a general loan died
adams wrote that he was sorry he had
taken the picture because lone was a
very good
person and had been destroyed by that
photograph uh but again it was a war
crime uh it shouldn't have happened but
there was incredible
uh
i don't know what would you want
mitigating circumstances perhaps he knew
this guy had just murdered
several families of of police officers
as far as what to do about vietnam i
think the answer
is to help the people of vietnam get as
educated as possible understand the
alternatives understand the benefits
of a free market society under the rule
of law they've already seen free markets
somebody said that vietnamese like
americans more than anyone the pew pound
pew foundation did a poll of people all
over the world
what's your attitude towards americans
vietnam
was number one in terms of positive so
we that's documentable it's true
uh and i think you know we obviously
need we have a lot of mutual interest
with vietnam today including
dealing with china uh i think it's in
our interest to work with them i think
it's also in our interest to encourage
them to consider
uh you know giving their people more
than they've given them you know well i
understand the french exploited the hell
out of vietnam for nearly a century
before world war ii i think roosevelt
was right i don't think anything good
came out of the french being there uh
but the uh uh
that's not what's going on now now the
vietnamese have the choice of joining
the free world uh having freedom and
democracy and i think the more we can do
and the more we can do to spread the
word there is a chance for somebody to
really go down in history as i hate to
use the american parallel but as the
george washington of vietnam you can use
a lot of other terms but as the person
who really gives the people of vietnam
freedom and i could see some people in
the party who have become disillusioned
and would say hey i want to be that guy
uh or that that woman uh
so uh i think we ought to keep the eye
on the prize we ought to help prepare
the people of vietnam so they understand
the alternative
uh we ought not use force
and well
with time i think we should you know
things should work out
yes i'd like to add to that
yes education is very necessary but not
sufficient
in order to create change in vietnam
change of regime
from dictatorship to democracy for
instance
we need to
create and foster a society-wide
resistance movement
resistance here doesn't mean using force
it's peaceful resistance movements where
everyone or the majority of the people
choose an attitude to defend their own
rights defend their own interests
in order to do that we need to get
people to know how to organize
themselves
someone talked about in the previous
panel that the companies are very very
excellent and and clever and skillful
and resourceful in organizing themselves
we need to do the same and the young
generation and we here as part of the
the vietnamese diaspora we have plenty
of experience organizing ourselves just
look around we have hometown association
we have
high school associations we have also
association in this country
and we therefore can share those
experiences with people vietnam directly
and that's how you foster a movement
across the country to resist and to
change
the regime in vietnam thank you
thank you very much i'm sorry that we
have no more time for more questions so
thank you speakers thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
this weekend on american history tv on
c-span 3
tonight at 10